hopefully you're here for variational
inference and Python my name is Austin I
work at I'm a data scientist in mana
Tate labs I'll talk a little bit about
my own today at the end because they
yeah they paid me to send them here so I
got to plug them a little bit but
that'll come at the end I like to say
I'm a recovering mathematician so I'm
really excited to be able to talk to you
all here about math and Python and how
they can come together and I think it
enable you to actually do less mass by
hand then you might have had to do you
know a year or two years ago to achieve
the same results and I'd also like to
thank you all for coming and the Capital
One and the PI data DC organizers for
this conference because I'm a minor
organizer of data fili I'm from
Philadelphia
we're kind of in preliminary talks with
Annika or the continuum focus folks
around having a data Philly conference
and boy is it a lot of print so for an
event to be this excellent they've done
a lot of work and so I really appreciate
all the work they've put in so let's
just start by kind of going over some
details of Bayesian inference because
variational inference is really kind of
just another approach to Bayesian
inference this is one of my favorite
pictures I think it's from a statistics
department somewhere in the UK I really
want one
I'd love to expense at some time but I
don't think my boss would pay for it
right and so what does this actually
mean
well the posterior distribution Bayes
and Bayesian inference is the joint
distribution divided by the marginal
distribution of the evidence hopefully
you know we're all at least vaguely
familiar with this not to many formulas
in my talk I promise we're going to get
to the Python pretty quickly the problem
is for many youths well Bayesian models
the marginal distribution of the
evidence this green quantity is harder
impossible to calculate analytically
right and so we have to resort to some
kind of approximate computation and
there's a bunch of kind of standard
would all call modes of Bayesian
inference right you can just restrict
yourself to conjugate models where you
can do the and do that calculation
that's no fun and kind of limits what
you can do Markov chain Monte Carlo
algorithms I think are probably the best
known and most widely used there's a
bunch of other ones there's approximate
Bayesian computation which I'll admit to
not knowing a lot about and then there
are what are called distributional
approximations
so there's my loss approximation which
you know is kind of like the the
fundamental trick of Statistics applied
to Bayesian inference and what's the
fundamental trick of statistics right a
power series and throw away everything
with that's higher than the linear term
or higher than the quadratic term it's
like the fundamental trick of
introductory statistics right applied to
posterior computation and then there's
INLA iterated nested Lacrosse
approximations which I also don't won't
say a lot about if there's also
variational inference and one of the
really exciting things is that over the
past couple of months to a year or two
there have been some nice emerging tools
to automate variational inference in
Python piggybacking off of some
theoretical advances in terms of
performing variational inference not by
hand on a wide range of models so that's
what I'm here today to talk about
so first let's kind of get a picture of
what normally happens right what's what
the Markov chain Monte Carlo algorithm
which is probably the the most the most
used approximation right what's the
fundamental idea construct a Markov
chain whose stationary distribution is
the posterior the amazing thing about
MCMC algorithms is that this is possible
a lot of the time but we take this for
granted now sample from the Markov chain
for what I'll call a long time what a
long time means is actually one of the
things that I want to talk about here
and then approximate posterior
quantities based on the empirical
distribution of those samples right and
so here I just have a little animation
of a Hamiltonian Monte Carlo algorithm
exploring normal posterior distribution
okay and so now let's get down to the
Python right this is a PI data
conference we want to start interleaving
Python and math pretty quickly so
throughout this talk we're gonna we're
gonna lean on kind of the simplest
Bayesian model you can have the beta
binomial model alright to illustrate
some concepts then we're gonna ratchet
up the more interesting models to show
you give you just a teaser of what you
can do with these play some packages so
suppose we have three successes in ten
trials right and we want to infer the
true success probability well let's
let's put a uniform prior on the true
success probability and one of the two
Python packages we're gonna be talking
about is pi MC
three which you'll see me using here
right and so this is how you translate
that math into Python using pi MC three
you declare a PI MC three model and you
say okay the probability of success in
my beta binomial model is uniform
between 0 and 1 I am somewhat of a
contributor to pi MC 3 minor contributor
I would say I really enjoy it and I find
it really fantastic that that you can
kind of just translate from that math to
that Python somewhat intuitively all
right and then the probability that we
have a success given our odds of success
well that's just P right and then so we
translate that into this Python a
Bernoulli distribution with P beta
binomial is its probability of success
and then what's really neat is there's
this observed very observed keyword here
that fixes that says hey we've observed
the number of successes we've observed
three successes and seven failures here
so this is how you kind of fully specify
this model in PI MC 3 right and the
advantage of this is this model is
conjugate right we know the true
posterior distribution is beta four
eight I hope I've made the embarrassing
mistake of forgetting to add once to
each of those but I think I did it right
so we know the prior and we know the
true posterior so this is going to be
kind of our basis for thinking about
variational inference a little bit now
what is Markov chain Monte Carlo do to
approximate this well we take our model
and we do this p.m. sample right I said
we sample from some Markov chain for a
long time right in this case five 550
thousand iterations and hey we can
approximate our su posterior
distribution pretty well with by the
just empirical histogram of those
samples right that's pretty good so this
is kind of the basic idea of Markov
chain Monte Carlo there's a million
different flavors but you get the idea
now so what are the pros here under some
fairly mild conditions this is
asymptotically unbiased which means
it'll get you the right answer if you
wait long enough for some definition
like I said before I've long enough
algorithms are somewhat model agnostic
you can give some model agnostic
algorithms you can of course speed
things up with model specific algorithms
but that's fine and well studied for
probably a while right since at least
the days of the Manhattan
when they had this idea of approximating
hard integrals through simulation what
are some of the cons here can take a
long time to convert right like I said a
long time and sometimes it can be
difficult to assess convergence because
you don't know what you're supposed to
be converging to right and also it can
be difficult to scale it can be
difficult to paralyze like you know you
can't just throw this thing out on a
spark cluster and expect it to give you
the right results you need to
synchronize too often there's there's a
lot of overhead here and I have a list
of references in the back there's one
really great like mini book that went up
on the archive late recently that
discusses kind of exactly what the
difficulties are there that I I think
everyone who's interested in this at a
technical level should read so now that
we kind of understand what the what the
kind of default go-to for Bayesian
inference in analytically intractable
models is let's let's introduce
something else something that's tends to
be a little more exotic variational
inference so what's the basic idea of
variational inference instead of trying
to find the true posterior eventually
what we do is we choose a class of
approximating distributions and then we
find the distribution in that class
that's closest to the true posterior
okay so this is interesting and
introduces some interesting trade-offs
that we'll talk about in a second just
on a kind of technical level it
minimizes this callback Leibler
divergence from the approximate
distributions q to the true posterior
that we can actually compute in red and
this is interesting this kind of gives
us a little grounding in information
theory right because what is minimizing
this actually minimizing it's minimizing
the number of bits extra bits you need
to encode samples generated from your
variational distribution using a code
optimized for your true posterior
distribution it's a disk it's a distance
measure between distributions but it's
an interesting connection with
information theory right the thing is we
can't calculate that red quantity up
here so this formula is basically
useless to us how do I calculate this
without calculating the red quality
fortunately through the the power of
logarithms that expands to this right
where we have this bracketed
distribution this bracketed quantity
that I'm calling the elbow evidence
lower bound plus that green distribution
the marginal distribution of the
evidence which is hard to calculate but
doesn't involve Q so we don't care right
if we're trying to maximize or minimize
this in terms of Q we can ignore that
green distribution because that's just a
number that doesn't depend on the
variational distribution okay and I mean
if we can't calculate the joint
distribution we have other problems and
should resort to other methods so enough
variational inference theory let's dive
into a quick example quick visual
example suppose this is our true
distribution that we're trying to
approximate using variational inference
now this we could probably calculate by
hand but whatever it's instructive and
the variational family we want to choose
is not write this as a two dimensional
Gaussian but it definitely has a full
rank covariance matrix right things are
definitely correlated here suppose we
want to approximate this with
uncorrelated Gaussian so right gaussians
that are with diagonal covariance okay
we can do this and and there's no I
actually meant to do this at the
beginning and then got excited I tweeted
the links to the slides and the notebook
my talk is based out of because if
you've ever looked at something like
this this is actually generated from an
eye Python notebook and it's just at
Austin Rochford my first name last name
I'll post that again at the end of the
talk so as you can see here on here's
the notebook this talk was generated
from and here's a docker file that
contains all the dependencies because
some of them can be a little difficult
to install so hopefully this talk should
be fully you know reproducible on your
computers if you're interested in it
afterwards so here's the variational
approximation we get if we ask our
normals to be uncorrelated now we can
see it's smaller we tend to overstate
our confidence so what are the pros and
cons of this well the pros in my mind
this is what really matters to me in my
professional life because I
I use these methods professionally is
that it's a principled way to trade
complexity for bias right the true
posterior distribution required for
covariance parameters the approximated
covariance distribution required to
we've reduced the complexity from N
squared to n right if you're a software
as a startup company that mine is you
have a couple hundred clients each of
which has a couple thousand models you
need to store these in a database you
need to pay Amazon for the discs to
store them on that reduction saves your
company money lets you predict faster so
one of the things I really like about
variational methods is that they give us
a principled way to say hey I know I'm
not going to get the right answer but
I'm gonna get the best answer I can
under the complexity constraints my
application can tolerate and another
great thing about it is that
optimization theory is applicable right
people have been working for a long time
on optimization algorithms so instead we
change the posterior calculation from
sampling to optimization and write a
little easier to assess convergence
sometimes here there's all kinds of
scalable optimization methods that have
really enabled machine learning over the
past 20 or 30 years right so people are
really good at paralyzing optimization
so this is exciting it's not all roses
right there are trade-offs and
everything in life what are the cons
what's a biased estimator of the true
posterior we just kind of buy that when
we buy this we say we have to see if we
can live with that bias in every
situation so sometimes it's better for
prediction predictive accuracy than
interpretation I don't necessarily once
when making policy decisions based on
this right if two variables are
correlated that's important to know in a
policy decision and if we force the them
to not be correlated in our answer that
might not be the greatest and a lot of
time there are models specific
algorithms you have to derive by hand
and I don't really want to go too deep
into this slide if this matters to you
mean field variational inference assumes
all of the quantities are independent in
your in your approximating class and you
can use coordinate ascent from this and
actually working out this first equation
that's where a lot of the hand
calculations come in it's easy for
things in exponential family
it's a little difficult other times it's
tedious and can be slow to converge
because you're updating one parameter at
a time so let's talk about how we can
automate that how we can not do calculus
by hand with Python I talk calculus for
five years while I was in grad school
by all accounts I'm pretty good at it I
still don't like doing it by hand right
so if I can get Python to do calculus
for me I will so the main theme of
automating variational inference in
Python is kind of two things one we want
to maximize the Elber yeah maximize the
elbow using gradient ascent instead of
coordinate ascent that'll go faster and
two we want to use some tensor libraries
I'll clarify what I mean by that in a
second to calculate the gradients
automatically to do calculus for us so
here's kind of a table of the two Python
packages I want to talk about the tensor
libraries they use and the variational
inference algorithms they implement them
the first is Edward it's out of a
research group in and I believe my U or
Columbia I think Columbia it uses
Google's tensor flow to do calculus
under the covers and parallel computing
all sorts of stuff like that
and it implements among other things I'm
simplifying here but what we're going to
talk about today is it implements
blackbox variational inference and then
there's also PI mc3 which like I said
I'm a little more experienced with I use
a lot its tensor libraries Theano if
you've ever heard of that it's kind of
an oral network it started in the neural
network world but it's useful for a lot
of other things and then implements
something called automatic
differentiation variational inference
we'll talk about what that means a
second so what are some of the common
themes here before we dive into actual
calculations we use Monte Carlo
estimates of the gradient okay so this
is a bit like stochastic gradient
descent all right and we use mini-batch
estimates of the Joint Distribution to
make this scale so a lot of data and
like I said this is a notebook and the
great thing about slides in notebooks is
you can have hidden cells that's how I'm
producing all these figures without
showing you a ton of matplotlib code
well I also included a lot of math there
for those that are interested so dive
into those hidden cells if you're
interested in the math behind this that
I'm Lee
out right now so black box variational
inference and a DVI they just arise from
two different ways of calculating that
elbow gradient you can do back calculus
a couple different ways you get some
different methods so now let's dive
straight into Python some Python
examples black box variational inference
is model agnostic in some sense there's
a and like I said the math details are
in here
it requires the ability to evaluate the
Joint Distribution okay well if you
can't do that we've got bigger problems
and you only need to differentiate the
variational distributions to calculate
elbow greatness here this is Edward's um
icon logo whatever it's a black box it's
pretty pretty clever I thought so I just
put that in there so let's get back to
our friend the beta binomial model and
see what does Edward do with the beta
binomial model so here's how we express
that same model we did before in PI MC 3
in Edward right we say P is uniform
between 0 and 1 X is a Bernoulli
variable with probability of success P
this is all pretty much the same slight
differences one had a context manager
one didn't then we map the data to the
same numpy array we say hey this is how
we tell Edward this X Edward beta
binomial was observed to be those three
ones and seven zeroes then we we tell
Edward what variational approximation
we're trying to use we say hey we're
gonna test say the posterior is also a
beta distribution well because it is
right and this tf+ variable that just is
some keeping I've buried that in the
hidden cell to do get tensor flow to
generate a variable it can optimize but
constrain it to be positive you can look
at the definition it's not that hard and
then we say hey in your approximate you
shouldn't replace p with QP that was
pretty pretty reasonable no nothing too
difficult here right and then we say go
do you mean field variational inference
with this system in this data run it for
ten thousand iterations pen hey we get
something that looks vaguely like the
true posterior reasons we don't get the
true posterior that the distance is non
convex so we can converge to local max
etc etc but this isn't too bad right
this isn't the worst thing in the world
peaked in the vaguely right region well
like I said Edward implements blackbox
variational inference one of the really
cool things about this is it doesn't
care how you tell it the probability
model so here we use this Edward dot
model stuff for P and X right
that's a thin wrapper around some tensor
flow distribution is just so Edward can
do some books I think so that's really
tensor flow going on for P and X well
since it doesn't matter Edward can
actually take a PI mc3 model and perform
inference on it because remember the
only thing edward needs to differentiate
is the variational distribution so we
can specify the probability model in pi
MC 3 here and one important thing is
that transform be none we'll talk about
what that means eventually pretty
similar and then we say okay here's the
the variational posterior here's the
system go do it right we're still
specifying the posterior using tensor
flow because Edward need some
differentiate that okay we got something
close if you ran them for a long number
of iterations they should converge to
the same thing they're test to that
effect in Edwards test so this is
interesting it's actually not quite
model agnostic and you can see that
because Edwards supports a lot of
modeling languages the first we saw was
those tensor flow distributions that
thin wrapper around tensor flow that was
Edward model see second is PI MC 3
it also supports Stan if you're into
that not a big stand user but it's just
a Markov chain Monte Carlo library in
C++ wrappers in R and Python it's kind
of big used by Andrew Gelman and people
like that you can also do direct density
calculations and I'll give an example of
that you can do that in tensor flow and
will paralyze it a little bit for you
you could do it in numpy or you can do
it in pure Python quite flexible and
what it accepts
so for each of these Edward and PI MC 3
how I'm gonna kind of structure this is
I want to give you a simple example of
the beta binomial model to wrap your
minds around what's happening then I
just want to tease how you can get more
complex and fit some interesting models
in these things as they are now even
though they're kind of rapidly evolving
so since we're in Washington it's almost
election time I wanted to do one of my
favorite examples as an armchair
political scientist congressional ideal
points so I've taken the University of
California Irvine
dataset on nineteen eighty-four
congressional votes I've loaded it here
and I've coded it with zero as voting
for the bill or voting against the bill
one is voting for the bill Nana's not
voting and coated party I think it's
zero is Republican one is Democrat you
can see this all in himself like I said
I have this all spelled out we want to
see how can we use just this vote data
to separate Democrats from Republicans
using n-word so here this just kind of
shows you what percentage of each party
voted for each bill that's kind of
interesting just just kind of some EDA
on this data what's the idea of this
model I want to give the idea and then
how that translates into Edward and it's
pretty intuitive I think representatives
and Bill's each have an ideal point on a
spectrum of conservatism political
science scientists have chosen to call
it conservative ISM instead of
liberality I don't know why but yeah you
just kind of fix which direction is off
right it's like physics it doesn't
matter which direction is up as long as
you're consistent so a representative in
the bill have the same ideal point in
terms of conservative 'ti there's a 50%
chance that representatives gonna vote
for that bill Bill's also have an
ability to discriminate between
representatives right because some Bills
have broad bipartisan support they're
not very good from telling ideology and
some are voted along party lines this is
really all we need to know to put this
model together so we put some priors on
here I'm gonna show the prior and the
code necessary to implement it using
Edward right so the representative ideal
points we just assume have standard
normal distributions right this isn't
too bad we we take a normal distribution
ask for its log PDF added up using
tensor flow
Bill's have ideal points and
discriminative abilities these are
hierarchical normal distributions right
normals that are constrained have saying
means drawn from the same distribution
variance drawn for the same distribution
why doesn't alpha have a hierarchical
system technical model identification
reasons you can there's a paper I put in
the references you can read that that's
what you need to do to identify this
model right and this is how we how we
implement that right we just have a log
normal prior or a normal prior on you a
uniform prior on Sigma and then we
evaluate the the prior just as before so
then this is just a logistic regression
model kind of given those things right
alpha minus beta times gamma stick it
through a sigmoid right so here we
basically have that I love seeing how
math translates almost exactly to Python
right sigmoid of gamma times economy
alpha minus beta and then just the
Bernoulli log PDF on that it's really
really beautiful and concise so to get
those functions into an Edward model
it's really simple you have to do some
bookkeeping where you unpack the
parameters from these dictionary X's and
Z's you are evaluate the prior you
evaluate the likelihood you add them we
put together our variational
distributions you can read a little more
about this later behind so we're going
to move forward and we say hey do you
mean feel variational inference on these
run for a while don't stop and hey look
we look at the posterior distribution of
endpoints and we have separated
Democrats from Republicans in very few
models lines of Python fairly quickly so
this is just neat and like I said not
like comprehensive if you wanted to use
this model in real life there are other
things you would do but just to tease
the things you can do with these
libraries is my goal here today a fun
project here and like I said I'm super
interested in this sort of thing would
be to recreate these this dynamic ideal
point model of the US Supreme Court in
Edward I think we're like 70% of the way
there with this code now you just need
to add a time series for some of these
things I think that would be a neat
thing that I may do eventually but we'll
also be happy to read someone else
having done
so like I said moving quickly because
I'm a little behind but it's the last
session of the day we don't mind if I
keep you from do you know I promise I
won't go too long if we need to take
questions to the happy hour we can
always do that so now we've talked about
Edward and black box variational
inference let's talk about variational
inference in PI mc3 Oh so this uses
something called automatic
differentiation variational inference
which is a mouthful here's the idea it's
only applicable to probability models
where you can differentiate everything
okay
so here we are explicitly requiring the
model be differentiable where we weren't
in B BGI what you do is take parameters
that have constraints on them like a
parameter that lives in 0 1 transform it
to live on the whole real line MA God's
transform I'll show this in a second
approximate all unconstrained posterior
z-- with the closest normal distribution
you can then then transform back for
things you you have to so let's see how
the beta binomial model works with this
so again in the constrained parameter
space where the probability of success
has to lie between 0 & 1 we've seen this
picture on the left before what we do is
we take this log-odds transform to allow
that price to allow that parameter live
on the whole real line the equivalent
prior and posterior are on the right ok
so now what did I say a DVI does it'll
approximate that blue distribution on
the right with the normal distribution
that's closest to it so I do a DVI on it
this is the same model I used at the
very beginning by the way right these
things are reusable they're pluggable
which is you know a really nice kind of
software engineering feature you can
either sample from the more doing or do
variational inference on them and so
this red curve is the advi approximation
to the transformed posterior right and
then I said we pull that back to the
constraint parameter space hey and we
get a pretty good approximation we get
what's probably a better approximation
than the Eduard one well that makes
sense because we're putting more
assumptions on the model in this case
right so we can get more out of it
that makes perfect sense right when you
when you put more assumptions on things
you can usually get more out so the the
example I'm really excited to talk about
here and this is just one of my favorite
models because I I really love Asian non
parametric's because I really hate model
selection
I really really hate fitting a ton of
models cross validating whatever any
chance I get to push model selection
into model fitting I will take so I
really love Bayesian nonparametric s--
because we're gonna model this as a
mixture distribution where the model
selects the right number of mixture
components in a hypothetically infinite
number and we're gonna do this on the
computer with pi mc3 it's gonna be
awesome
so here's some data from a Larry
Wasserman's excellent all of
nonparametric statistics he uses a lot
of examples we're gonna use it's
interesting data it's got a couple of
different trends in here it's not
homoscedasticity make sure I get the
term right so what's the idea that we're
going to implement here a mixture of
linear models with an unknown number of
mixture weights whoo-hoo and the mixture
weight is allowed to depend on the X
variable all at once to kind of
illustrate the things you can do with PI
mc3 so just an idea hey here are three
lines that look like we might be able to
mix them to fit this pretty well but I
don't know let the data decide right
like I said I hate model selection
closed within the model fitting whenever
I get the chance so let's put a prior on
our mixture weights all right so we're
gonna do what I call a logistic stick
breaking process you can read a paper
about this in my references that's right
and we basically just have RIF
regression coefficients alpha and data
so alpha plus beta X we're gonna put
that through a sigmoid function then
we're going to do something called the
stick breaking process not that
important you can read about it in some
of the references this is how we turn
this prior into a prior on infinitely
many weights and I say infinitely many
but we actually truncate decay here
we'll see why that's alright in the end
because right computers can't compute
with infinitely many
things they're bad at this is how this
model gets translated into Python it's
pretty intuitive I think I really dig
this there's some magic hidden in the
stick breaking function but I promise
it's not that much magic and you can
read what it is in one of the hidden
cells one of the really neat things here
to pay attention to is I've declared
this X lidar as a Theano shared variable
we'll come back to that in the end that
lets us do easy posterior predictions
with that X we'll see what that does in
a minute after we finished specifying
our linear model then right we set a
mixture of linear models so here's just
you know K Bayesian linear models for
each component right I'm not going to
dive too much into this but this is not
direct translation from Python to math
again a thing that makes me really happy
and then the observation model is just a
mixture model like I said right it's the
eyes linear regression with probability
X I and that's this is how we specify
that so we take this we say with our
lidar model let's do some advi right we
get this beautiful elbow chart
alright this beautiful graph of the
evidence lower bound which looks like
it's converging right one of the
benefits I said of this is a lot easier
just to visually diagnose whether you're
converging or not and notice since we're
getting noisy estimates of the elbow
right if you're used to like e/m
algorithms or convex optimization this
is not increasing at every step right
you might in a lot of optimization
routines you might look and say crap my
bug my code has a bug because this
should be increasing every step since
we're using noisy estimates here that's
not the case but that's okay we're
increasing in general and one of the
really cool things about PI mc3 that you
can also do that I said before was using
that shared variable that basically
tells Theon oh hey I may change the
value of this later pay attention so
here I said just a grid of points that I
want to predict that STD ranges the X
the standardized x value here I'm just a
hundred grid points between the smallest
and largest I swap the X variables I fit
the model with for the X variables I
want to predict on and then I ask PI mc3
to do posterior predictive sampling for
me
it's pretty cool this takes a little
while and we can examine first the
impact of that truncation I said now if
we truncated too soon we would see
mixture weights with positive mass on
them all the way out to the right here
or pretty far to the right all right so
the fact that there is no mixture weight
with the preacher but positive mass in
it past 10 when we probably didn't okay
job truncating this is a heuristic it
works pretty well there's a paper in the
references you can read about truncated
stick breaking processes and hey here's
our posterior prediction and it looks a
little wacky right it's a it's a little
jumpy because of our our bias but that's
pretty cool right I think it's pretty
neat that we did this Bayesian
nonparametric mixture with potentially
infinite number of components where the
component weights depended on X all on
my macbook without too much work without
blowing it up too bad so this is kind of
what you can do in PI MC 3 there are
some references here that you can get in
the length section on Edward and PI MC 3
variational inference in general models
some of the specific models so whatever
you're intrigued on learning more here I
hope I've sparked your interest to learn
a little more about something here and
that book I mentioned is this patterns
of scalable Bayesian inference at least
skim it if you enjoy this sort of thing
it's really interesting thank you very
much my name is Austin I'm a data
scientist in mana Tait we're an
e-commerce software as a service company
we have eight years of e-commerce
interaction data to play with a hundred
billion page views we observed in 2015
we witnessed a third of us ecommerce
dollars spent it's a really fun place to
work a fun place to do modeling we're
not hiring at this exact moment we will
be again in the future and I love to be
in touch with smart people when we are
so please tell them get my business card
give me yours ask me questions about
mana tape maybe a happy hour or
variational inference now and just thank
you so much for your attention into the
PI data DC people for putting this off
Oh does anyone have questions yeah here
look so I can see certainly its
uninterpretable but like I said I did
tweet it from just at Austin Rockford so
if you look on the if you look at me
it's really just at my name on the on
the conference thing there's a tweet
that'll take you to the link to the
slides and the notebook is that does
that answer your question sorry it's a
bit roundabout innovation I didn't see
you there yeah it's a jist sorry yes you
know I have not read that book in a
while my guess would be something like
generalized additive models smoothing
splines something something but I
haven't read that book in a while that's
just an example I have in the back of my
mind the lidar where it's a mixture of
linear things that's hetero homo skid
not
right so I should be I should be better
about repeating the question for those
who will watch the recording later the
question was in the work I do do I use
the full posterior distribution or do I
just reduce it to point estimates the
answer is yes I use the full posterior
distribution a fair amount it's really
useful in like some active learning
algorithms that require randomization to
have beliefs that already have a
distribution to them you can just sample
from for your next believe so situations
like that I definitely do use the entire
posterior distribution and do not reduce
it to a single point and it's actually
kind of crucial for those situations and
I like I said Edward and Pines III kind
of emerging I'm putting them into
production I use them sometimes for EDA
I've certainly used a great effect kind
of hand calculated variational inference
at work to do that do exactly what I
said before turn difficult problems from
sampling problems to optimization
problems turn them into streaming
imprints and reduce the memory
complexity like that's that's the thing
I've been able to do a lot at work and
so it's a I think a really profitable
thing to learn if that's your niche
really useful thing not just as a
mathematician I find it intellectually
stimulating but it's also done a good
job for my company any other questions
yes you mentioned that this gives you a
principled way to tackle them the
highest greatest trade-off with
regularization of approaches that have
like a parameter to slide around it
appears to me that the way you get at
the bias variance is to choose your
class of models is there any analog
that's like you know tuning parameters
or the bias-variance tradeoff well and
so this isn't exactly the bias-variance
tradeoff right because we're training
like complexity for bias here right and
actually a lot of times are we will end
up increasing bias and under estimating
variance the the lever you can really
pull there and there's not like as much
of a cross-validation way to pull it as
there would be with like lasso or Ridge
regression which you know our
asian-inspired if not exactly Bayesian
is that variation that class of
approximating distributions right if you
make those more comply
it's going to be a harder optimization
problem but you're going to get less
bias if you make it less complex it's
going to be an easier approximation
problem with more bias so that's kind of
the lever you can pull here and that's
what's really interesting you can say
hey I can only tolerate linear
covariance parameters do the best you
can so that that's the lever you can
pull does that make sense any other
questions
awesome well thank you all so much for
coming and listening to me talk about
math at the end of a long two days and
like I said feel free to find me out in
the hall if you have any other questions
about this or Monty if you'd like to ask